Hey, everyone here.
We'll be taking a look at Stay Even Analysis.
What it is and why you might use it.
Let's say you're thinking about lowering your price to boost sales.
It feels intuitive.
Drop the price, attract more customers, make more money.
But here's what's easy to miss.
If you cut your price, you're giving up profit per unit.
That means to earn the same total profit, you'll need to sell more units, sometimes a lot more.
In this case, we've lowered our price from $10 to $9, and we need to sell an additional 10 units just to make up that shortfall.
So the real question isn't will I sell more?
It's how much more do I have to sell just to break even?
That's the logic behind Stay Even Analysis.
It allows you to determine the quantity required to offset a change in cost, price, or or other revenue factors.
It's a simple but powerful tool to test whether a price change makes financial sense.
Let's say you sell a Software subscription for $100 per month.
Your marginal cost, that is what it costs to serve one more customer, is $40, and your contribution margin is 100 minus 40 divided by 100 or 60%.
Now, suppose you're considering a 10% price cut from $100 to $90 just to stay competitive.
You'll make less per customer.
But if more people sign up, you could still come out ahead.
Perhaps.  Let's run the numbers.
The Stay Even formula that we're going to use is Stay even quantity percent.
That is how much we need to maintain where we were.
That's equal to the price change percent or the 10% that we saw earlier divided by our contribution margin.
In this case, it was 60%.
So this gives us a state even quantity of 10% divided by 60%, or approximately 17%.
So to make the same profit after cutting the price, you'll need to increase your sales by at least 17% or a 17% volume increase.
Sounds abstract, but if you sell 1,000 more.
If you sell 1,000 units per month, that's 170 extra units you have to sell or generate 15, 300 in new revenue at $90.
So turning that percentage into a concrete sales target helps teams internalize the challenge of can our campaign really deliver 170 extra units this month?
If not, we shouldn't cut the price.
If you can do it, then that's great.
But if demand isn't responsive enough, you may end up working harder and getting less in return.
Now, a note on the formula that we Just used.
There are two common formulas that we can use and one and they're both suited to different business contexts and have different assumptions.
The first formula here is used in economics, pricing strategy and marginal analysis.
This version assumes a direct trade off between profit loss per per unit and the volume of units sold.
So it's making it's well suited for long run pricing models or strategic planning.
The output tells you how much quantity must increase to offset the loss in unit profit.
This is useful when considering price adjustments in a broader business model.
The second formula, the one above here, the one that's used in the text, is more common in retail marketing and promotional pricing analysis.
It's especially useful for short term discounting decisions.
This formula adjusts for the price lost relative to the full price, making it more accurate in scenarios like flash sales or seasonal promotions.
The output represents an adjusted quantity increase needed to stay even, assuming both price and contribution are working from a percentage base.
In summary, the first formula is better for strategic long term pricing decisions, while the second is ideal for tactical short term promotional campaigns.
Now let's take it a step further.
Let's use state even analysis with historical sales and then do a few reverse engineering calculations.
Let's say that we have three different pricing campaigns.
We're going to run different discounts in these.
Here we're going to have our structure.
Well, first let's clarify one thing.
In the first scenario, we're going to assume that our contribution margin is held constant, just to simplify the comparison and isolate the effect of the price discount and sales volume lift.
So we have our three campaigns.
We have our original price of $100 across all three.
We have three different discounts, 10%, 15% and 5%, which gives us new prices of 90, 85 and $95.
And we kept our contribution margin the same at 60%.
Now what we want to do is calculate the stay even quantity percentage for each of these different campaigns.
And we're going to do that right here.
So we got 16.7%.
We've already seen this.
We divided the 10% by the 60%.
Now we're going to do campaign B and C, divide the 15% by 60% to get 25% and the 5% by 60% to get the 8.33%.
Now the actual volume gain, what actually took place when we ran these campaigns, now these are made up numbers, but you would actually do this in a real world scenario.
The actual volume gain was 20% for Campaign A, 18% for Campaign B, 12% for Campaign C and what we see is that campaign A and C were profitable with their discounts of 10 and 5% respectively.
But campaign B wasn't because the stay even volume gain percentage that we needed was 25%.
But our actual volume gain was only 18%.
So that was a loss making result and one that we tried to avoid.
Now, now let's take a look at what happens when we allow our contribution margin to vary.
So here we're going to have our new contribution margins.
The prices and discounts and all those things were the same.
But our new contribution margins do change from 60% to 55.6, 53 and 58%.
Okay, so now we take those contribution margins and we take the original discounts to figure out what our stay even volume gain percentage is.
And now we have 18%, 28.3% and 8.6%.
So what again we notice is that campaign A and campaign C were successful because they were still profitable, but campaign B was not.
It was still a loss making campaign.
So what we see is that we underperform at discounts of 15% or greater.
So in this case, we could use this information going forward to help us figure out what the price we should set just to make sure that we still remain profitable.
Now let's look at what happens when we're curious about reverse engineering some price cuts.
So we want to know if I can only realistically increase volume by 10%, how much can I lower price without losing profit?
So we're going to set up the formula to be the max price drop percent that we can have is equal to the expected volume gain percent.
In this case, 10% right here times our contribution margin.
We were using 60% as our contribution margin and this gives us a max price drop percent of 6%.
So we can afford to drop our price by 6%.
We should not drop it anymore or discount it any more than 6% unless we are confident that our volume will increase by more than 10%.
Now we can also build a reverse calculator here.
We could use this for managers.
In this case, it's going to give us a realistic forecasted volume gain.
It's also going to give us a product contribution margin.
And it looks something like this expected volume gain.
Now these are what we would expect built off of past experience.
5, 10, 15 and 20% the different contribution margins and you could adjust these based off of different things and then max allowable discount.
So let's look at this table.
If we think sales will rise by 5%, then we can afford to offer up up to a 3% discount only on any price.
Now any more than 3% and you're going to lose profit.
So unless your sales increase by more than 5%, you don't want to offer more than a 3% discount.
A 10% expected sales lift, that is the expected volume gain percentage there gives you room to offer up to 6% discount.
That's our break even limit there.
Price cuts above this level require bigger sales jumps to justify it.
15% sales increase can justify it to a 9% discount and then a 20% expected volume gain percentage can justify up to a 12% price cut or discount.
So this decision support tool here helps us or tells us if we only expect a month modest volume boost, we can't afford a big discount.
Lower our contribution margin is, the more limited our discounting options become.
And vice versa.
So why does this matter?
This is a tool for smarter pricing here.  Stay even.
Analysis doesn't tell us what price to choose.
It tells us what needs to happen after a price change is especially helpful when we're running discounts or temporary promotions, entering new markets and testing pricing strategies, or if we're facing pressure to match competitors.
It also ties back to elasticity.
If our product has elastic demand, you may be able to increase sales by 20% or more, making the discount worthwhile so you can adjust your prices down.
But if you have inelastic demand, adjusting prices down may cause you to lose more revenue than what was justified.  So stay even.
Analysis is a reality check.
For us, it's the difference between guessing and planning.
Because pricing isn't just about how much you sell, it's about how much you keep.  And that's it.
Hope you've enjoyed it.